[Musique] la
nuit tombe il se réveille maître très cool
oui peux-tu descendre une
seconde s'il te plaît
les problèmes de vivre avec d'autres
vampires ce sont les vampires avec qui j'ai choisi
de rester je voulais parler de
l'hygiène générale dans la cellule hier soir
il y avait tous  ces gens là-bas à
moitié ivres, où ai-je trouvé l'alcool
non, ils étaient à moitié ivres,
ils ont été à moitié ivres si vous avez
quelque chose à dire,
ce n'est pas hygiénique,
aucune porte n'est comme une grosse dinde, vous ne pouvez pas
vous tromper avec eux  Je suis vraiment désolé, donc on
peut me jeter des pièces de monnaie anciennes, le
montant des crédits, cet homme gemo est mon,
je ne suis pas un tueur, je trouve des gens qui sont
faciles à tuer des vierges à la maison, vois à quel point
c'est pertinent,
Colleen, que fais-tu ?  ici, c'est
ma chambre, je m'appelle Callan
Robinson, salut Deb et je suis un vampire énergétique,
soit nous t'ennuyons avec une longue
conversation, hey Don
ou Don, nous te mettons en colère, maître, c'est
prima carb, mon gâteau est coincé dans la porte.